Hi, I'm Michael Littman.
You may remember me from such courses as
Machine Learning, Intro to Algorithms,
and well, this course.
>> Hi, I'm Chris Pryby.
I'm a course developer with Udacity,
and I worked with Charles and
Michael to build this course.
>> Where is Charles anyway?
>> You know what,
let's just add him in post.
>> The main goal of this course
is that you become prepared to
engage with the reinforcement
learning community.
One aspect of being engaged with
the community is becoming familiar with
software built specifically for
solving reinforcement learning problems.
To help you with this goal,
you will use a java framework called
the Brown UMBC Reinforcement Learning
and Planning library, or BURLAP.
>> In this tutorial lesson I
will introduce you to BURLAP and
help you write your first
programs using the library.
We'll talk about how to set up and
solve a basic MDP using BURLAP.
>> As you work through the course,
we encourage you to think
about the planning and
learning algorithms presented, and
try to implement them using BURLAP.
A great resource to consult
is the BURLAP documentation,
available at the URL listed
in the instructor notes.
>> All right, Michael,
ready to get started?
>> I'm ready.
>> Awesome, yeah!